okay now that you've seen how to create
a pull request let's take a look at what
happens when someone else make changes
that conflict with your pull request
sarah has said that my poor request
looks good but she has also made a pull
request I can see it here in the list of
pull requests it looks like she
increased the amount of oil to put in
the cake so that it would be more moist
since our changes affect the same line
it will mark them as a merge conflict so
one of us will have to resolve the
conflict I'll go back to this screen and
merge Sarah's changes first and then
I'll need to resolve the merge conflict
yes confirm and since Sarah only created
the more oil branch in order to make
this pull request into master it's safe
to delete the branch now now when I go
back to my pull request I see that it
can't be automatically merged anymore
this is because performing emerged
between the master branch and my branch
would now cause merge conflicts rather
than having you resolve the merge
conflicts in the browser github requires
you to merge the changes on your own
computer and then update the pull
request with the merged version let's go
to Sarah to talk about how you would do
that here's what the recipes repository
would looked like on github before
caroline merged in my change notice that
I've left some of the earlier changes
out this time because I'm a little bit
pressed for space here's the branch that
I created to add more oil to the recipe
and here's Caroline's branch the
different kind of oil with the
misspelling and master at this point is
still unchanged and here's what the
local version looks like my changes
aren't there because she hasn't pulled
since the last time she pushed what do
you think happened in this diagram when
Caroline clicked the button to merge my
branch into master you might be
remembering when we talked about fast
forward merges and how since master is
an ancestor of more oil master might
just get updated to point to the tip of
the more oil branch that would be a
great guess that's actually what I would
have expected but it turns out that even
when you could have had a fast-forward
merge merging with the button on github
will always make a commit anyway even if
no extra information is given by making
that merge commit after clicking the
button to make this merge commit
Caroline also deleted this branch github
makes this very easy to do after a merge
and it's pretty common to want to
actually get rid of this branch
because usually it's named for the
specific purpose that that branch was
serving and once you merge it in it's
pretty much at the end of its life so
we'll go ahead and remove it from the
diagram as well so this is what github
looks like at this point now Caroline
wants to update her pull request to
include my changes
if merging these two branches wouldn't
cause a conflict I could actually just
pull in her request now but since we
changed the same lines she's going to
have to pull these changes over into her
local version so she'll need to pull
master this will update her local
version with all the commits on master
that aren't already on her version so
this one and this one and it will also
update origin master there wasn't an
obvious place to put this since there's
so many things attached to this commit
and I'm a little low on space so here's
an arrow to show you that this is
attached to this commit remember
Caroline's eventual goal is to get her
change into the master branch up on the
github repo so you might be tempted to
think she should just merge her branch
into master and push it up this is
basically what happened the last time we
had a merge conflict but remember this
time we're using pull requests to
communicate our changes to one another
so if Caroline just merged her branch
into master and pushed it up I wouldn't
have a chance to check out her updates
and make sure that her changes still
looked good before she updated master in
this collaborative environment it's
often only acceptable to make changes to
master through pull requests since
otherwise things can change out from
under you without notification so
Caroline will need to make the fixed her
branch fix the typo for canola and then
merge in master into her different oil
branch and then push her branch up to
github which will update the pull
request so that I can look at that
before merging it back into master